abenteuer alpen wird ihnen präsentiert
von lego ja ok der geschmack der schweiz
seit 1115 tag 4 auf der obhut der
berühmtesten skitour von chamonix nach
zermatt
wiedereinsteigern fast 45 grad
fränzi aufdenblatten und dominique gisin
in beiden ehemaligen skirennfahrerinnen
wagen die abfahrt ein seil muss es für
die anderen richten einsturz hätte
fatale folgen
[Musik]
die gruppe ist heute seit bereits sechs
stunden unterwegs
es ist mitte und heiß vor ihnen liegt
der gefürchtete lange abschnitt entlang
dem lack die dies hoffe und wofür man
spüre dass ich schwul
das stimmt schon früh aber genau das ist
der vierte tag der härteste und längste
der tour gewarnt wurde die gruppe
bereits am vortag von bergführer david
hasler
80 km
7000 höhenmeter in sex tag das ist die
oms ein pensionär ein heilpädagoge
eine kaufmännische angestellte zwei
skirennfahrerin
ein ziel und eine haushalts lehrerin
wollen sich diesen traum erfüllt
gestartet sind sie heute um 5 uhr in der
kabine vor
nach fünf stunden erreichten sie die
rosa blau und nun befinden sie sich in
der langen fläche entlang des lac de
dies vor dem aufstieg zur cabane dies
eine etappe von neun stunden 17
kilometer mit 1800 metern aufstieg in
großer hitze severin oder allianz gruppe
swiss zieht mit olympia siegerin
dominique gisin vorneweg gefolgt von
peter dem heilpädagogen aus zürich
bergführer david phasen drängt aufs
tempo die maschine den ich muss sparen
da wird sie mir auf der fläche die
kontrolle habe das erwartet hatten
aber das können hier schläft nachts
wachte ich mit dem nordhorner ich bin
das problem besteht bis heute
aber da hätte aber sogar das auffällig
später ist man immer der fahrer ja es
ist ja hast du public key also ja ich
bin mir der schweizer alpen mitglied
vertreten
ja ja die natur das wetter sie können
über leben und tod entscheiden wie sich
auch auf der hut einige tage später
zeigen die gruppe hat sich inzwischen
getrennt
david welt mit severin freund sie
dominik yolanda und peter die strecke
hoch über dem stausee ich mir nicht
wichtig ob das die lawine hat
leichtfertig vor der gebiete heißt da
dieser wird sie traut sich gute stück
handgepäck arrangement niedrig dass der
72 jährige brown und carmen sind mit
bergführer ralf weber derweil weiter
unten am lac de dies unterwegs die sonne
brennt kaman bereiten die blasen an den
füßen immer mehr schmerzen und noch
liegen 600 meter aufstieg vor ihnen
um das wasser das schaffen wir die türen
der therme ich lange unterhosen abziehen
und hier wieder darüber habe ich mich
lange unter wasser
noch läuft das nicht nur so staubt
richtige dreck ja was mit liefer
austauschen die hüter des 0 3 aber
paulina ständig überträgt das zdf
schenkt
auch die schnellere grippe leidet unter
der frühlings hitze das ziel die grande
dies ist nach achtstündiger skitour
immer noch nicht in sicht
bild zeigt 0
es wird große war nicht nur sage fit wie
ein turnschuh
doch das war noch gar nichts bietet man
uns zu wohnen wo das sie mit logo und
schlafe der beliebte wir babys wendige
glück zweiter hinter und dann beim
bremsen versagt
naja
carmen nimmt's mit humor
doch plötzlich ist die schneedecke unten
am stausee voller eisschollen und risse
die schwer sichtbar sind
paul bleibt in einer spalte stecken
bergführer real versucht kamen und paul
sicher durch die spalten zone zu lotsen
nachdem wir die schlecht war die an
beziehungen können
kurz vor dem ziel und doch noch weit
in der ferne die garantie dies und auch
peter ist mit dabei
er der morgen alles infrage gestellt hat
was ich selbst severin der ehemalige
zehnkämpfer kämpft weiter unten hatte
half die skis von carmen und paul ein
stück hinauf getragen
damit sie schneller vorwärts kommen
endlich nach über neun stunden kräfte zu
ihren natur erreicht die erste gruppe
die garantie diese und peter wird zum
held ziemlich erschöpft aber am schluss
geht definitiv in form um in die
leistungsfähigkeit mit temperatur
korreliert und und nicht zu schnell
dasselbe team sowie 44 und weiss musste
sich am schluss hält niemand will und da
verdammt sie
die untere teil am regener
christusträger danach hat man also von
kuppen und dort immer wieder überqueren
und dann plötzlich mit einem ausstieg
und ann-christin etwa eine halbe stunde
das gestell und dann laufen wenn ein
roboter gut gelebt ist doch der
cee-länder vor der tour gebrochen hat
nun wartet sie auf ihren vater bestand
ja noch vor über 50 jahren hat paul die
ortrud schon einmal gemacht
da das sagt stark also gemeinsam noch
einmal auf der hut ein traum für beide
posten entschuldigung
[Gelächter]
nach über zehn stunden recht auch carmen
das ziel
das komitee öoc spiel
[Musik]
die hütte ist voll rund 120 tourenfahrer
sind an diesem tag ende april auf der
route unterwegs von hütte zu hütte die
morgige etappe beginnt in der kabine
dies es folgte aufstieg über die golden
share putin auf die bühne der roller auf
fast 4000 meter dann hinunter über den
goldene weg ins biwak die butter
wieder muss die gruppe eine 8 stündige
tour mit über 14 kilometern und 1500
höhenmeter bewältigen
[Musik]
start ist um fünf uhr morgens der winter
zugelegt
[Musik]
die gestrige tour hat spuren
hinterlassen carmen start mit schmerzen
die er seiner gehalten
er ist eigentlich fit sieht es noch
gange und letzten platz
das wetter ist noch gut doch eine
schlechtwetterfront wird erwartet
eigentlich war sie bereits für den
heutigen tag angekündigt
auch paul spürt die anstrengung von
gestern ein teil des gepäcks hat ihm
severin bereits abgenommen
[Musik]
auch berg viele ralf weber hilft es ist
hochsaison auf der haut mehrere
skitourengänger aus der ganzen welt sind
den gruppen unterwegs um sich ihren
traum zu erfüllen
[Musik]
steil bergauf mit heißen den steighilfen
an den schießen geht es auf den golden
set
quer durch gewaltige gletscher abbrüche
über spalten verdeckt vom schnee des
letzten winters
vielmehr ist zu haben
da nein stopp vor dem heikelsten stück
des aufstiegs können wir dann nach
führung
wenn man uns gesellschaften für euch
nach europa händische flachen stein ja
also ich glaub sich bewegt gartner der
kondition über schalter aber dass
letzten ecken mit den schienen der
typisch passiert da ich gerade einmal
eine steil fällt eine wand aus fels und
eis richtung norden
darüber der vereiste steilhang zur linie
der roller den es zu überwinden gilt
eine kritische schlüsselstelle in der
david und ralf als bergführer gefordert
dort stieß als sie noch nicht einholen
und der kraft sparte automobile auf
untersuchungen bis zum 17
dass der bau reagieren
ja
[Musik]
ralf und david haben die gruppe geteilt
am seil und aufsteigern geht es über den
vereisten schnee
der winter zugelegt es ist kalt vorboten
der schlechtwetterfront
[Musik]
wie nahe das leben und tod auf einer
solchen tour beieinander liegen zeigt
sich zwei tage später als eine andere
gruppe an dieser stelle in einem sturm
gerät die orientierung verliert und
sieben personen in der kälte ums leben
kommen
so schnell können sich die verhältnisse
ändern so groß ist auch die
verantwortung der bergführer gegenüber
ihren gästen die ihnen vertrauen
der allmählich doch für sammler
und jetzt auch nach dem gestrigen tag
der hand andere fürchtet dass das
billige wird rufen
ich habe ganz gut das schwierige für
kondition freue mich gut erholen
das ist ja sehr gut es brennt da müssen
wir ganz immer
es folgen die letzten schritte auf die
bühne der roller mit 3700 90 meter dem
dach der tour
bei guten bedingungen haben es alle
geschafft
auch paul der vor 50 jahren zum ersten
mal genau auf diesen punkten stand
ja ich will sehen natürlich nehmen wir
haben hier drauf war dass ich dumm oder
in aussicht die für alle strapazen
entschädigt
doch im ritz und stauen sich bereits die
wolken und es ist noch weit und endlich
wieder einmal eine abfahrt
[Musik]
bevor es in die nächste steigung geht
die wolken front rückt immer näher
david zieht vorne weg ralf kümmert sich
um kamen die spieler dürfen es nur
irgendwie lief es dem kunden würden
also machen wir doch wenn sie zügig
unterwegs
nebel kommt auf es stürmt
doch david kennt den weg
jetzt worden leibovitz waren warme hier
über klimadaten wir müssen jetzt
schnellstmöglich zu verbessern und hoch
und gibt es von norwegen nachmittag man
sie geht es für sie ja dem hat das gut
diese schritte langsam aber sicher
ebenso flüssig kondition ist gut dass
ich mir im praxisteil macht damit wieso
bei machen mit aber so wie groß im
rennen das von trust inc
und ich bin in gedanken schon die
nächste und übernächste woche sie was
sind so die nächste ziel von neugeschäft
wie kann man das auch unter mac dass ich
bin und danach wieder grüne abhängen
konnten als bester
[Musik]
ihr ziel heute ist das biwak die butter
ein biwak das hoch über dem gletscher
liegt es ist nicht bewirtschaftet
verfügt aber über eine kochgelegenheit
und brennholz ein platz mitten in der
abgeschiedenheit weg vom rummel der
großen hüten und nur noch ein tag von
ziel dem matterhorn in zermatt entfernt
ich sitze auch was aber ist ein novum
ist schneeschmelze hätte wasser und hat
viele surfer thema so wichtig sei es
auch die haube sorgt der linie wachen
entspannung nach fünf tagen
anstrengungen der nutzer nur abrückt und
nur passend dass der vermieter muss wenn
eine gemeinschaft von
aber nicht weil sie nicht anders aus und
die sind nicht will ja ja inzwischen
nach regenbogenfisch und hersteller 150
meldet muss aber mache den bruchstellen
defekte dahin wird ein user gsohn film
ich weiß dass ich jetzt selber mit
solistischen auftritt besitzt nein für
mich es ist sowohl motivierende wir
befriedigender für mich auf dem kurs
stieg auf den boss und zwar nicht nur
spannend gefunden
es ist eine wirklich viel
alle menschen wollen oben sein
das ist einfach dass ich zwei tage
voller strapazen diese gefordert und
eindrücke die sie geprägt haben liegen
hinter der gruppe
hauswirtschaftslehrerin jolanta
übernimmt das kochen gemeinsam mit reif
kurz vor dem ziel noch einmal ein moment
für alle darüber nachzudenken warum man
sich den traum und router füllen wollte
ich eine sehr schöne tour wochen kommen
das ist wunderbar druck sie mega
mitgemacht landschaftlich einmalig sie
bis ganz gezielt und mutig werden ist es
passiert aber ich habe noch viel vor
spieler sind extrem die größe die bürger
das ist mir bewusst dass ich gut mit
dieser zusammen um so wieder machen
die tagestour machen oder 2 oder
vorstellen dass man einfach das ist sehr
spezielles wie zuletzt immer ob sie
sieht dass wir es gemacht haben
polituren gdl suchen
ist gold bugs ich glaube ich möchte vor
allem mit gesprochen
nein ich glaube dass er wieder mit mit
frische und motivation wieder an apps
frage wo man sich etwas mehr mut
overlack noch eigentlich unnatürlich
niedrig also landschaftlich ist schon
wirklich eine woche lang wenig studieren
und das schon als erholen sie einfach
mal selber keine unlösbare problem im
kopf wollte das hatte dank völlig kunst
gegend wenn das irgendwo womit
beschäftigt davon drei optionen er hat
das gut funktioniert und das fällt nicht
auf die eintritte das gerichtlich nicht
mehr abhängig ist von der einzelperson
und was mich aber auch daran dass
sexualität ist ruft den alleine zu
machen immer mal machen und und mit
alzheimer das zu machen ist subjektiv
durch verschiedene sachen treiben wo in
der welt machen besitze ich habe die cdu
noch die ganze geschichte viele menschen
unterwegs
so lebt er in übersee wie stark ist das
bis 17 jahre hat denkt wird wesentlich
mehr sie die erinnerung und alles
schlief vekselberg nur mit mir
beschäftigt xii oder mit roma dass das
gar nicht zum thema warte ist und ich
weiß jetzt dass ich das gemacht glaubt
großer platz zwei für den oscar
nominiert
etwas für meine kirche stellte die pappe
mit viel also
er kann gerne zwecke es ist so schnell
vorbei
also ja ja ganz verschiedene jeder kann
also ich es gerne gegen die benennen
will sich viele sich wesentlich besser
gelaufen als das sie denkt ja das kleine
zukauf passe
[Musik]
noch einmal um fünf uhr aufbrechen noch
einmal im schein der stirnlampen auf dem
gefrorenen gletscher zum letzten
aufstieg war
die letzte etappe führt sie vom biwak de
buck tor zum golde laval berlin mit
blick aufs matterhorn
darauf folgt eine lange abfahrt nach
zermatt eine genutzt wenn das wetter
stimmt
rund 20 kilometer rund 1500 höhenmeter
liegen noch einmal vor ihnen
ja stimmen ich bin nur noch gelaufen war
die rot rot ist auch eine geschichte
über menschen an ihre grenzen kam
[Musik]
sie lernten mit steigeisen zu klettern
16 überwinden und gemeinsam als gruppe
an das ziel zu glauben
[Musik]
das vor stunden fehlen
und zur ende dieses abenteuer nach sechs
tagen in den hohen bergen mit einem
blick aufs matterhorn
[Musik]
darf ich doch
und dass menschen die sich vorher nicht
gekannt haben wurden freunde
[Musik]
dass ich im auto
nachdem gordon brown hat sich das auch
anhört und paul ii mit der versteigerung
[Applaus]
einige wollen mutig andere zu helfen
jeder hatte sein persönliches ziel auf
dieser tour des lebens
denn manchmal ist es eben an der zeit
aus dem alltag auszubrechen und im leben
ein neues kapitel hinzuzufügen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
abenteuer alben wurde ihnen präsentiert
von hygiene hopi der geschmack der
schweiz seit 11 115
[Musik]